a big loss in hollywood the passing of
goodfellas star ray liotta at the age of
67.
the shocking news leota died in his
sleep in the dominican republic while on
location for his next project the dark
drama dangerous waters e.t has learned
there is no foul play suspected in his
death and no investigation pending
the last time ray was spotted in public
was just over three weeks ago out to
dinner with fiance j.c natolo in
california as far back as i can remember
i always wanted to be a gangster
it was leota's breakout film goodfellas
in 1990 that made him hollywood's go-to
tough guy to laugh laugh crazy like with
joe pesci is fun to
to beat people up you know and make
believe is fun
romancing lorraine brocco is a lot of
fun
today co-star lorraine bronco paid
tribute to her longtime friend they
always ask what was the best part of
making that movie my response has always
been the same ray liotta robert de niro
added he is way too young to have left
us may he rest in peace
if you build it
he will come
from field of dreams with kevin costner
to blow with johnny depp and guest
starring roles in sitcoms like young
sheldon and modern family ray did it all
but there was one role he was always on
the lookout for i would like to do
something extremely romantic i really
would where i'd finally have to you know
i don't have to choke the girl to kiss
her it wasn't romantic but ray did find
on-screen chemistry with jennifer lopez
in shades of blue i feel like when we do
our scenes together something really
great happens jlo wrote today rey was
the epitome of a tough guy who was all
mushy on the inside he was so kind to my
children
ray is survived by his only child carson
who never bought into her dad's tough
guy persona it's kind of hard to take
him seriously it's kind of funny like i
don't know i just kind of laugh at the
end of the day all you want is people to
be entertained that's it
just a shock when ray we were enamored
and entertained by everything you did